So to quickly summarize this
part of how to build panoramas,
we basically went into details what five
steps are used to generate panorama.
Talked about image re-projections,
specifically with, for
the cases of panorama building.
Introduced the whole
concept of homography and
how it can be computed
from two pairs of images.
And then also introduced
the whole concept of RANSAC,
to allow to deal with good matches and
bad matches and that could be used for
a variety of things including assisting
us with being able to find the most
reliable features, and also,
perhaps finding panoramas, and
then we talked a little bit about
additional things that we need to know
about panoramas, including projection
models and stuff like that.
Again, this is just scraping the surface
on the whole idea of panoramas but
again, there are lots of other readings
that I'm going to be asking you to
look at that'll help you build a better
understanding of these panoramas and
we'll do a simpler assignment
on panorama building but
also know there are lots of
softwares out there that you can use
to learn how to do this kind of stuff.
Additional reading that you
should look at include these.
There is a whole lot of literature
out there I encourage you to look at.
There's also publicly available
softwares that you can play around with,
and also commercially
available softwares.